[Musik]
die omikron welle erfasst china die null
corvette politik vor dem scheitern
millionenmetropolen gleichen
geisterstädten
die propaganda präsentiert einen
funktionierenden staat
wer eine andere sicht zeigt bekommt
ärger
[Musik]
ist der verrückt
was machen sie sie können doch nicht so
auf mich zu fahren
was macht ihr denn hier fragt er wenn
ihr drehen wollt müsst ihr das vorher
beim bezirk anmelden
wer ist wird er uns nicht sagt
wahrscheinlich vom nachbarschafts
komitee wir wollen in peking eine der
vielen wohnsiedlungen drehen die im
lockt einstecken das ist leider was
immer wieder passiert wenn immer wir die
maßnahmen zeigen wollen mit dem auch
hier in der hauptstadt peking corona
bekämpft wird sind die offiziellen sehr
sehr nervös und der werden eigentlich
sofort daran gehindert
dieses video hat man ins geschickt es
zeigt die anwohner die am morgen vor
ihrem ausgang stehen und nicht mehr raus
dürfen die behörden haben ohne
vorwarnung nachts um drei ihre siedlung
dicht gemacht
sie haben ja abgeriegelt ohne etwas zu
sagen erst als wir morgens zur arbeit
gehen wollten stellt mir fest der
ausgang ist geschlossen
der wohnblock ist von außen mit
stacheldraht gesichert in dieser
siedlung leben mehr als 15.000 menschen
vor allem viele amis so werden die
haushaltshilfen in china genannt die für
wohlhabendere familien arbeiten jetzt
verdienen sie kein geld mehr müssen
zusehen wie sie ihren alltag meistern
eine bewohnerin zeigt uns ihre vorräte
die sie noch in ihrer küche gelagert hat
sie muss haushalten schau mal mainzer
kreis so viel habe ich davon noch
zuhause für einen monat sollte es wohl
reichen
wir versuchen woanders mit den leuten
ins gespräch zu kommen es gibt immer
wieder beschwerden dass die
lebensmittelversorgung in der quarantäne
nicht optimal funktioniert doch die
menschen haben angst mit uns zu reden
sie werden immer wieder von der polizei
verscheucht
[Musik]
wir vertreiben niemanden in der pandemie
muss man abstand halten
auch die orte die nicht unter quarantäne
stehen werden seit beginn der pandemie
vor zwei jahren streng kontrolliert
auf diesem schild steht kontrollstation
und jeder der hier rein will muss eine
gesundheits app zeigen wenn der kot
grünes der verein solche stationen gibt
es viele in peking wo man sieht ihm die
nervosität in der hauptstadt und die
angst davor dass es eine mikrowelle gibt
[Musik]
in hongkong hat die omikron welle vor
gut zwei monaten ihren ausgang genommen
die behörden der dichtbesiedelten
metropole unterschätzten am anfang die
ansteckungsgefahr bis dann rasend
schnell die infektionszahlen in die höhe
schnellten
das gesundheitssystem der stadt cham an
seine grenzen die
krankenhäuser konnten die vielen
patienten nicht mehr aufnehmen
die bilder von den alten die im freien
lagen hat das land geschockt und
alarmiert so etwas kannte china nur aus
dem ausland die null kowitz strategie
hatte versagt
die todeszahlen stiegen in dramatische
höhen die behörden mussten sage
ranschaffen und mobile kühlcontainer für
die vielen leichen aufstellen damit sie
bei der hitze nicht verwüsten seit mitte
februar hat es mehr als 8000 tote
gegeben
die omikron welle wird ganz china
erfassen erklärt uns der virologe wenn
paul ii er hat die daten aus hongkong
ausgewertet
ich glaube es wird immer schwieriger
werden ausbrüche zu verhindern zum einen
weil das omikron virus ansteckend ist
zum andern weil die leute die
kontrollmaßnahmen leid sind
hongkong hat die schwäche des corona
kontrollsystems gezeigt viele menschen
sind sorglos gewesen weil die
infektionszahlen zu beginn der pandemie
in china niedrig waren nach
inoffiziellen zahlen galten bis vor
kurzem noch 130 millionen der über 60
jährigen als nicht ausreichend geimpft
in den letzten wochen haben die behörden
verstärkt versucht dies zu ändern
die meisten schweren verläufe von
corvette und die meisten todesfälle
erleiden ungeimpfte ältere menschen
es ist ein wettlauf gegen die zeit die
omikron welle rollt durchs land die
propaganda will einen handlungs starken
start präsentieren mobile krankenhäuser
werden aus dem boden gestampft bilder
die an den ersten ausbruch in woran
erinnern
[Musik]
tencent rafft die omikron welle als
nächstes die nachbarstadt von hongkong
hat rund 17 millionen einwohner ein zaun
trennt beide städte seit monaten ist
diese grenze dicht normalerweise
überqueren sie täglich hunderttausende
die strengen grenzkontrollen konnten
nicht die ausbreitung des omikron virus
in shenzen verhindern im februar begann
der lockdown die straßen menschenleer
bei gerade mal einigen hundert fällen
[Musik]
handy aufnahm die chinas behörden nicht
schnell genug zensieren konnten zeigen
wie eingesperrt sich die menschen fühlen
mitten durch die wohnviertel der stadt
zieht sich eine mauer die bewohner sind
verzweifelt schreien lasst uns raus ich
kann es nicht mehr aushalten beendet die
quarantäne
[Musik]
die lage in shenzen hat sich
normalisiert dafür spitzt sie sich in
shanghai zu der anderen
wirtschaftsmetropole des landes in den
sozialen medien finden wir dramatische
szenen die uns erschrecken
[Musik]
shanghai chinas stolze 26 millionen
metropole hat die omikron welle nun voll
erwischt seit mehr als einem monat
leidet die stadt unter dem lockdown
steht das leben still
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
die dramatische lage geben viele videos
in den sozialen medien wieder
hamsterkäufe haben die regale gelehrt
wir verhungern niemand hilft uns schreit
die frau am fenster
in shanghai herrscht panik frust und
angst
einige nachbarschaftskomitees in den
ärmeren wohnviertel rationieren das
gemüse
ich habe kein geld mehr um essen zu
kaufen
der vater schiebt seine tochter zum
krankenhaus die öffentlichen
verkehrsmittel sind nicht mehr im
betrieb ein pfleger stoppt den man die
medizinische versorgung scheint zusammen
gebrochen zu sein er bekommt keine hilfe
er soll wieder nach hause gehen sagt der
sicherheitsbeamte aber wir können doch
nicht mehr erklärt der vater die antwort
aber das ist nicht unser problem
aufnahmen im netz sollen provisorische
quarantäne unterkünfte in einem
erbärmlichen zustand zeigen
ich mache mir sorgen wegen der
bedingungen in den krankenhäusern ich
habe angst dass mein baby den aufenthalt
nicht überlebt
die staatliche propaganda verschweigt
die katastrophe sie zeigt
funktionierende teststationen modern
ausgestattete mobile krankenhäuser
und eine gut organisierte
lebensmittelversorgung
inzwischen sendet der staat aber das
militär zur unterstützung der
hilfskräfte nach shanghai eine
dramatische maßnahme um das chaos in den
griff zu kriegen
im shanghai leben auch einige tausend
deutsche viele müssen jetzt mit einer
schwierigen lage klar kommen wir
sprechen mit familienrecht seit fast
zwei wochen dürfen sie ihre wohnung
nicht mehr verlassen
wie lange die quarantäne noch geht sagt
ihnen keiner sie versuchten fit zu
bleiben essen haben sie genug aber das
gemüse wird knapp manchmal helfen die
nachbarn einen stock tiefer
wir haben keins mehr die sympathischen
nachbarn aus dem ziel haben doch bei
papier
not macht erfinderisch
sein hunger aber es gibt einige
lebensmittel die fehlen und mit
steigender quarantäne dauer
steigt auch das dass das unwohlsein
darüber dass man
was die ernährung anbelangt sehr
limitiert darauf ist was hier quasi in
den kom fortgefahren wird in ihrer
wohnsiedlung leben knapp 1000 menschen
vorwiegend ausländer sie ist komplett
abgeriegelt
trotzdem denken die behörden über noch
schärfere maßnahmen nach da kriegt man
abends um
21 heute nacht werden alle wohnungen
frei sie gehört damit sichergestellt was
wirklich keiner mehr die tür aufmachen
kann da gab es da gab es hier auch in
unserer nachbarschaft
emotionen da wurde wurde geweint da war
da war man unfassbar wenn man das gar
nicht glauben kann dass in der
wohnanlage schon abgeschlossen ist dass
man dann auch auf die idee kommen
wohnung zu versiegeln um nochmal um
nochmal radikaler sicherzustellen dass
wirklich keiner die tür aufmacht die
familie darf nur ihre wohnung verlassen
wenn sie zum corona test geht
die einzige möglichkeit ein wenig
bewegung und frische luft zu bekommen
jetzt hoffen wir dass er
heute abend über die ergebnisse
solche videos im netz machen der familie
angst eine zeit lang haben die
shanghaier behörden die infizierten
kinder von ihren eltern getrennt familie
anriss tochter ist gerade mal eineinhalb
jahre alt es gibt ja viele
medienberichte darüber dass kinder von
eltern getrennt wurden es gibt
medienberichte darüber dass wenn man
positiv getestet wird dass man
irgendwelche großen lagerhallen mit
10.000 betten england geschickt wird das
gebe ich zu sind für mich als
familienvater schreckensszenarien die
möchte ich um alles in der welt
vermeiden und deswegen
haben wir jetzt für ende april einen
lufthansa flug nach frankfurt gebucht
und ich hoffe und bete dass er auch
abhebt und dass wir irgendwie eine
chance haben werden den compound zu
verlassen und meine beiden mädels hier
raus zu bekommen
es gibt nun ein wenig hoffnung in
shanghai für einige wohnviertel haben
die behörden den lockdown aufgehoben sie
sind corona freigänger im eigenen land
[Musik]
chinas führung hat sich lange für ihre
corona politik selbst gefeiert für
präsident sie demonstriert die null
kowitz strategie die überlegenheit des
chinesischen systems der ausbruch
beschädigt nun das image der
kommunistischen partei
das große versprechen wahr dass chinas
besser kann als der rest der welt das
heißt china als unter kontrolle während
die anderen im chaos versinken das ist
die storylines seit anfang 2000 20 und
diese große natürlich mächtige story
wird ihnen jetzt zerschossen das heißt
die kp-führung hat im grunde an der
stelle wirklichen großen verlust zu
erleiden weil diese sonderstellung china
sie an der bekämpfung von corona
weltweite sonderstellung unser system
ist das überlegene diese story können
sie dann nicht mehr weiter so spinnen
präsident steckt in einem dilemma
lockert er die kontrollen muss er mit
mehr toten vor allem in regionen mit
schlechter medizinischer infrastruktur
rechnen bleibt er bei seiner 0 covic
strategie muss er millionenmetropolen
lahmlegen und damit chinas wirtschaft
nachhaltig schädigen
wenn china in irgendeiner form auch nur
teilweise ausgeknockt wird durch solche
lockdown
industriestandorte
dienstleistungsstandort helfen usw da
heißt es dass die ganze welt das spürt
mit verzögerung vielleicht von 12 wochen
aber das geht sehr schnell
wir sind unterwegs zu pekings
stadtgrenze normalerweise wimmelt es
hier vor autos doch nun kommen nur
wenige nach peking ein nur wenige wollen
die hauptstadt verlassen sie ist
abgeregelt wie eine festung die vielen
scooter stehen verlassen am straßenrand
die besitzer sind vor den toren pekings
stecken geblieben es braucht wahnsinnig
viele genehmigungen von verschiedenen
behörden erklärt und helium in die
eigene hauptstadt einreisen zu dürfen
sie benötigen einen ausweis einen
negativen corona test einen nachweis des
nachbarschafts komitees wo man wohnt und
wo man arbeitet und einen arbeitsplatz
nachweis des arbeitgebers
viele hundert tausend pendler kommen
jetzt nicht mehr zu ihrer arbeit nach
peking verdienen kein geld mehr die
einfachen leute können so nicht
überleben sie rufen hebt den lockdown
auf lasst uns raus
[Applaus]
dieses land kontrolliert sich ins
abseits und verharrt immer mehr in der
bewegungslosigkeit
selbst die geschäfte und straßen rund um
die verbotene stadt wirken verweist
touristen kommen keine mehr
nur einige pekinger hochzeitspaare
verkleiden sich mit traditionellen
uniformen sie vergessen für wenige
stunden dass auch der hauptstadt härtere
maßnahmen drohen und die omikron welle
die festung peking längs durchdrungen
hat